Toronto June 1981 among the man at
Toronto's busiest firehouse George Evans
stands out he's a little big man I was a
smallest guy in the truck but I was a
strongest guy in the truck he's in peak
condition five feet eight and 90 kilos
of muscle
I had a gym in my basement I had a gym
at the fire hall I was always pumping
iron
on this early summer evening a roof fire
breaks out at the Confederation Life
Building a six-story office in downtown
Toronto 20 trucks respond you Ross sees
the roof is about to go
I could see up through the open elevator
shaft the peak of the building and it
was starting to waver
everybody said get the hell out it's
everybody out the next thing I know was
the roof collapse
I feel like a pile driver hit me on the
top of the head George is flattened by
debris that was a tremendous thump I'm
in the dark now like laying on my back I
guess it gets worse the weight of the
Fallen roof is too much but down on the
fourth floor
pounded out of the third floor they
found that on the second floor
George has lived only to face death
again
trapped under a 270 kilo beam he can't
breathe 18 by 18 solid hardwood an
enormous weight if he doesn't move the
beam he'll die but it's twice what he
can benchpress worse he's crippled by
dislocated shoulders
George should be completely immobilized
by such severe injuries
he's in agony but his body has an
antidote his brain instructs the
pituitary gland to release endorphins
the body's natural painkillers the
endorphins lock into receptors in his
nervous system and block pain messages
from reaching his brain results
temporary euphoria George's body is also
primed with adrenaline his heart is
pumping extra oxygen and sugar to his
muscles as well as to his brain as a
result his mind is focused on a single
task
the surge of endorphins and adrenaline
gives George the boost he needs he
pushes through the pain barrier the
third key to his survival
George spent nine days in intensive care
six weeks in traction three and a half
months in the hospital and two years in
painful physiotherapy then he returned
to work as a firefighter after 30 years
on the service he made district chief he
retired in 1997 to this day his survival
confounds the experts